the version control system plays a vital
role in any software development project
it allows you to track changes in the
source code git is a very popular
distributed version control system use
for source code management hi guys
welcome to this complete gif tutorial by
simpler our instructors Matthew and
sadhana on having industry experience
working with several DevOps tools will
help you learn get in detail first we'll
understand what is DevOps and look into
an introduction to DevOps then we will
see how to install git on Windows
following this we will learn about git
tutorial with hands-on demo finally we
will run through some of the most
important git commands let's first look
at a small animated video to understand
the basics of DevOps beep tim-tim builds
robot in his lab a climate controlled
and pollution-free environment once he
is done he drops the robot off at his
project partner Mia's house Mia takes it
out to her backyard to ensure that the
robot meets the requirements but here is
where the problem arises the change in
the environment causes the robot to
malfunction
Mia is now really annoyed and she has a
lot to correct and it seems to her as
though Tim didn't really do much this
wall between them leaves the poor robot
to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
me Anna work together in a common space
tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as a man a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product the
developer common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective
would be the developer while Mia the
operations their union is the core of
the DevOps approach DevOps has several
stages and set of tools to automate each
of these stages let's have a look at
these Tim first puts down a plan in
terms of a software
this could mean deciding on the modules
and the algorithms to use once he has
the plan he now codes the plan with
tools such as gift tim has a repository
for storing all the codes and their
different versions this is called
version control next this code is
fetched and made executable this is the
build stage tools such as Gradle and
maven will sorts out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular tool
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested Mia must deploy the
deployed product is then continuously
configure to the desired state ansible
puppet and docker are some of the most
common tools used that automate these
stages now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
Nagios is one such tool that automates
this space and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the code of the DevOps life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration let's now have a look at an
organization that has adopted the DevOps
approach which of the below sequence of
steps would they follow to develop a
software leave your answers in the
comment section keep an eye out for the
right answer on the comment section or a
YouTube community giant such as Amazon
Netflix Target Etsy and Walmart have all
adopted DevOps and seen a considerable
increase in
and quality in 2014 and our of downtime
for Netflix would cost two hundred
thousand dollars it became absolutely
crucial that Netflix prepared themselves
for any sort of failure and so they took
to the DevOps approach and implemented
it in the most unique way they developed
the tool called simian army this tool
created failures and automatically
deployed them in an environment that did
not affect the users the team would
troubleshoot these failures and this
give them enough experience to deal with
any degree of collapse with everything
being automated and happening
simultaneously organizations can now
deliver at a much faster pace so
considering the benefits of DevOps and
its divergence from the traditional
methods word DevOps be the future I hope
that has got you interested in learning
more about git now we have Matthew
Anjali and chai Ganon's who will take
you through the journey of learning get
in detail over to Matthew now hello this
is Matthew with simply learn and today
we're gonna go through and introduce you
to DevOps when it go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at DevOps and how DevOps
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical
DevOps delivery and then the tools use
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within DevOps finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
DevOps brings to you and your teams so
let's go through waterfall so what aful
is a traditional delivery model that's
being used for many decades for
delivering solutions not just IT
solutions and digital solutions but
either way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War two
so waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and they cascade
each
deliverable through a series of
different stage gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution that build out
their applications that build out the
website and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against of the agile code you'll
do manual testing you do UI testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks but the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very
time-consuming
also if you spend weeks and months away
from your clients and you deliver a
solution that they are only just going
to see after you spend a lot of time
working on it they could be pointing out
things that are in the actual final
application that they don't want or are
not implemented correctly or lead to
just general unhappiness the chance you
then have is if you want to add
in the clients feedback to restart the
whole waterful cycle again so the client
will come back to you with a list of
changes and then you go back and you
have to start your programming then you
have to then start your testing process
again and just you're really adding in
lots of additional time into the project
so using the waterfall model companies
have soon come to realize that you know
the clients just aren't able to get
their feedback in quickly effectively
it's very expensive to make changes once
the team's have started working and the
requirements in today's digital world is
that solutions simply must be delivered
faster and this has led for a specific
change in agile and we start
implementing the agile model so the
agile model allows programmers to create
prototypes and get those prototypes to
the client with the requirements faster
and the client is able to then send the
requirements back to the programmer with
feedback this allows us to create what
we call a feedback loop we're able to
get information to the client and the
client can get back to the development
team much faster typically when we were
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
sprint and then typically a sprint will
last for about two weeks
some companies run sprints every week
some run every four weeks it's up to you
as a team to decide how long you want
actually run a sprint but typically it's
two weeks and so every two weeks the
client is able to provide feedback into
that loop and so you were able to move
quickly through iterations and so if we
get to the end of sprint 2 and the
client says hey you know what we need to
make a change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for
and three what we have here is a
breakdown of the ceremonies and the
approach that you bring to agile so
typically what will happen is that a
product leader will build out a backlog
of products and what we call product
backlog and so be just a whole bunch of
different features and it may be small
features or bug fixes all the way up to
large features that may actually spent
over multiple sprints but when you go
through the sprint planning you want to
actually break out the work that you're
doing so the team has a mixture of small
medium and large solutions that they can
actually implement successfully into
this four into plan and then once you're
to start running your sprint again it's
a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the agile sprint
team to ensure that everybody is staying
on track and if there's any blockers
that those blockers are being addressed
effectively and immediately the goal at
the end of the two weeks is to have a
deliverable product that you can put in
front of the customer and the customer
can then do a review the key advantages
you have of running a sprint with agile
is that the client requirements are
better understood because the client is
really integrated into the scrum team
they're there all the time and the
product is delivered much faster than
with a traditional waterfall model
you're delivering features at the end of
each sprint versus waiting weeks months
or in some cases years for a waterfall
project to be completed however there
are also some distinct disadvantages the
product itself really doesn't get tested
in a production round it's only being
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually
install the software and make sure that
the environment is running in a stable
fashion that is really difficult to do
when you have the two teams really not
working together so here we have is a
breakdown of that process with the
developers submitting their work to the
operations team for deployment and then
the operations team may submit their
work to the production servers but what
if there is an error what if there was a
setup configuration error with the
developers test environment that doesn't
match the production environment there
may be a dependency that isn't there
there may be a link to an API that
doesn't exist in production and so you
have these charges that the operations
team are constantly faced with and their
challenge is that they don't know how
the code works
so this is where DevOps really comes in
and let's dig into how DevOps which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so DevOps is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
ops team and the dev team and so with
DevOps what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that
it's based on data so let's step through
the different phases of a DevOps team so
typically you'll see that the dev ops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to agile and
what I'd like to point out at time is
that again agile and DevOps
are very closely related but agile
devops arc
related delivery models that you can use
with DevOps it's really just extending
that model with the key faces that we
have here so let's step through each of
these key phases so the first phase is
planning and this is where we actually
sit down with a business team where we
go through and understand what their
goals are the second stage is as you can
imagine and this is where it's all very
similar to agile is that the code is
actually start coding but they typically
they'll start using tools such as git
which is a distributed version control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as mavin
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and j-unit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get around we can start scripting
out these environments and so we
actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tours such as ansible and chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can just
zero in on spikes and issues that are
relevant
to either the code or changing consumer
habits on the site so let's step through
some of those tools that we have in the
DevOps environments so here we have is a
breakdown of the DevOps tools that we
have and again one of the things I want
to point out is that these tools are
open source tools there are also many
other tools this is just really a
selection of some of the more popular
tools that are being used but it's quite
likely that you're already using some of
these tools today you may already be
using Jenkins you may already be using
git but some of the other tools really
help you create a fully scriptable
environment so that you can actually
start scripting out your entire DevOps
toolset this really helps when it comes
to speeding up your delivery because the
more you can actually script out of the
work that you're doing the more
effective you can be at running
automation against those scripts and the
more effective you can be at having a
consistent experience so let's step
through this DevOps process so we go
through and we have our continuous
delivery which is our plan code build
and test environment so what happens if
you want to make it release well the
first thing you want to do is send out
your files to the building ramp and you
want to be able to test the code that
you've been created because we're
scripting everything in our code from
the actual unit testing being done to
the all the way through to the
production environment because we're
testing or that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production environment if however your
code passes the the scripting tests they
can then be deployed and once it's out
to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases
to agile which is two weeks or four
weeks depending on your sprint cadence
to where you are today with DevOps where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
Google Google any given date will
actually process 50 200 new releases on
their website through their DevOps teams
in fact they have some great videos on
YouTube that you can find out on how
they're developed teams work Netflix is
also a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced DevOps within
their development team and so they have
a DevOps team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the DevOps team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all Internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
DevOps can be when you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that DevOps has it's the actual time to
create and deliver software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment you're improving the
communication between all your teams so
teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted
thanks Matthew that was great now Angela
will teach you how to install git on
Windows a very warm welcome to all of us
I am Anjali from simply learn and today
I'll be showing you the installation for
git on Windows so we'll start by
downloading and installing it on our
system will then have a
I advocate bash interface will type in
some basic git commands next we'll
create a local repository that is we'll
create a repository on a local machine
will then connect to a remote repository
and finally we'll push the file onto
github first things first we need to
download and install git so download get
for Windows and I'll select the second
link so two point one nine point one
which is the most latest version of kit
that's the one we want for Windows
system choose your version so mine is a
64-bit system and it's downloading so
this will take while so git is finally
downloaded now we need to install this
on our system click here run so go to
next we don't have to change this path
just so just click on in quick launch
and on desktop next next again next
nothing to change here either
and install so now git is getting
installed on our system so we don't need
to view the release notes we just want
to launch the git bash so let's just
stick that and then click on finish and
you get bash interface appears here so
we are on the master branch the first
thing we do is we check the version 4
again so the command is get - - version
and as you can see version 2.1 9.1 on
our windows system which is exactly what
we just downloaded will now explore the
help command so let's just type get help
config so config is another command and
as I hit enter the manly page for the
second command opened up which is config
so what help command does is that it
provides the manual or the health page
for the command just following it so in
case you have any doubts regarding how a
command is used what a command is useful
or the various syntax of the command you
can always use the help command now this
another syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config - -
help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir test now test is my
new directory I'll move into this
directory so CD test great so now that
we are inside afters directory let's
initialize this directory so git init is
the command for initializing the
directory and as you can see as you can
see the path here this is the local path
where a directory is created so I just
show you the direct shear test and it's
completely empty what we do now is we'll
create a text file within this new
directory that we created so new text
document and I'll just name this demo
I'll open this and just put in some
dummy content so Hello simply Don save
this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so git status and as you can see our
file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the gate tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to a current
directory the next command that we'll be
applying is the commit command and when
you add certain files to the current
directory the commit command is applied
on all the above directories so git
commit - M and a message that will
appear once the file is committed so as
you can see one file is changed and one
insertion I'll just clear the screen
next thing we need to do is we need to
link our get to our github account so
the command for doing that is git config
global user dot username and this will
be followed by our username so let me
just show you my github account so this
is my github profile and my username is
simply learn - github so guys before you
begin this procedure just make a github
account type in my username here simply
LAN - github and enter and there you go
a git is successfully linked with github
next thing we do is we
open our github and we create a new
repository give a repository name so
I'll give name a test
underscore demo and create repository
great
so our repository is created this is our
remote repository what we do next is
just copy the link and then go back to
your bash interface now we need to link
our remote and our local repository so
get remote origin and then paste the
HTTP link and now that our local
repository and a remote repository are
linked we can push a local file onto a
remote repository so the command for
doing that is git push origin master as
we are on the master branch and that's
done so now let's move back to github I
just click on test demo and as you can
see here a local file has been pushed to
our remote repository with that we have
successfully completed our demo thanks
Angela now Matthew and shadonna
will take you through the remaining part
of the course hello this is Matthew from
simply 1 and today we're going to go
through and explain how you can use git
for your software development so what
are we going to cover today so we're
going to introduce the concept of
version control that you will use within
your DevOps environment then we'll talk
about the different tools are available
in a distributed version control system
we'll highlight a product called git
which is typically used for version
control today and you'll also go through
what are the differences between git and
github you may have used github in the
past or other products like get lamp and
we'll explain what are the differences
between get and get then services such
as github and get lab will break out the
architecture of what a get process looks
like and how do you go through and
create Forks and clones how do you have
collaborators being added into your
projects how do you go through the
process of branching merging and
rebasing your project and what are the
list of commands that are available to
you and get finally I'll take you
through a demo on how you can actually
run git
yourself and in this instance use the
software of get against a public service
such as github alright let's talk a
little bit about version control systems
so you may have already been using a
version control system within your
environment today you may have used
tools such as Microsoft's Team
Foundation services but essentially the
use of a virgin' control system allows
people to be able to have files that are
all stored in a single repository so if
you're working on developing a new
program that such as a website or an
application you would store all of your
version control software in a single
repository now what happens is that if
somebody wants to make changes to the
code they would check out all of the
code in the repository to make the
changes and then there would be an
addendum added to that so there'll be
the version 1 changes that you had then
the person would then later on check out
the code and then be a version 2 i'm
added to that code and so you keep
adding on versions of that code the
bottom line is that eventually you'll
have people being able to use your code
and that your code will be stored in a
centralized location however the
challenge you run in is that it's very
difficult for large groups to work
simultaneously within a project the
benefits of a VCS system a version
control system demonstrates that you're
able to store multiple versions of a
solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional version control systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed version control so in a
distributed version control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest and piece of code so a key part
of a distributed version control system
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local
systems and they try and keep it updated
all the time it is the role of the
distributed VCS server to ensure that
each client and we have a developer here
and developer here and developer here
and each of those our clients have the
latest version of the software and then
that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS as environment
is get now you may remember that we
actually covered get in a previous video
and will reference that video for you so
we start off with our remote git
repository and people are making updates
to the copy of their code into a local
environment but local environment can be
updated manually and then periodically
pushed out to the git repository so
you're always pushing out the latest
code that you've coach entered you made
into the repository and then from the
repository you're able to pull back the
latest updates and so your get
repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get git
is a distributed version control tool
used for source code management so
github is the remote server for that
source code management and your
development team can connect their get
client to that certain remote hub server
I get is used to track the changes of
the source code and allows large teams
to work simultaneously with each other
it supports a nonlinear development
because of thousands of parallel
branches and has the ability to handle
large projects efficiently so let's talk
a little bit about get vs. github so
gate is a software tool whereas get ha
is a service and I'll show you how those
two look in the moment you install the
software topher get locally on your
system whereas github because it is a
service it's actually hosted on a
website yet is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas github is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on the service on the website
itself Gate provides command-line tools
that allow you to interact with your
files
whereas github has a graphical interface
that allows you to check in and check
out files so let me just show you the
two tools here so here I am at the git
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do version control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
hub as a way to be able to store your
files so get can communicate effectively
with github there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to github gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tool so the latest
version of Visual Studio Team services
also provides this same ability but
github it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where you can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to github and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects in fact
I think there's something like over a
hundred thousand projects being managed
on github at the moment that numbers
we actually much larger than that and so
if you are working on a project I would
certainly encourage you to start I get
hard to see if somebody's already maybe
done a prototype that they're sharing or
they have an open-source project that
they want to share that's already
available em in github certainly if
you're doing anything with them Asha
you'll find that there are thousands
45,000 Asha projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough github
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embracing open source
technologies so that's essentially the
difference between get and github one is
a piece of software and that's get and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
github so let's dig deeper into the
actual gate architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your git
project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you want to
put out all your changes to a local
repository after you made your changes
and these will commit those files and
get them ready for synchronization with
the service and will then push your
services out to the remote repository an
example of a remote repository would be
github later when you want to update
your code before you write any more code
you would pull the latest changes from
the remote repository so that your copy
of your local software is always the
latest version of the software that the
rest of the team is working on one of
the things that you can do is as you're
working on new features within your
project you can create branches you can
merge your branches with the mainline
code you do lots of really creative
things that ensure the that aid the code
remains a very high quality and B that
you're able to seam C add in new
features without breaking the cork
so let's step through some of the
concepts that we have available and get
so let's talk about forking and cloning
and kids so both of these terms are
quite old terms when it comes to
development but forking is certainly a
term that goes way way way back long
before we had distributed CVS systems
such as ones that were using with get to
fork a piece of software is a particular
open-source bone project you would take
the project and create a copy of that
project and but then you then associate
a new team and new people around that
project so it becomes a separate project
in entirety a clone and this is
important when it comes to working with
get a client is identical with the same
teens and same structuring as the main
project itself so when you download the
code you're downloading exact copy of
that code with all the same security and
access rights as the main code and then
you can then check that code back in and
potentially your code because it is
identical could potentially become the
mainline code or in the future now that
typically doesn't happen your changes
are the ones that merge into the main
branch but also but you do have that
potential where your code could become
the main code with gates you can also
add collaborators that can work on the
project which is essential for projects
where a particular where you have large
teams and this works really well when
you have product teams where the teams
themselves are self empowered you can do
what a concept was called branching in
git and so say for instance you are
working on a new feature that new
feature and the main version of the
project have to still work
simultaneously so what you can do is you
can create a branch of your code so you
can actually work on the new feature
whereas the rest of the team continue to
work on the main branch of the project
itself and then later you can merge the
two together pull from remote is the
concept of being able to pull in
services software the team is working on
from a remote server and get rebates is
the concept of being able to take a
project and
establish a new start from the project
so you may be working approach where
there have been many branches and the
team has been working for quite some
time on different areas and maybe you
kind of losing control of what the true
main branch is you may choose to rebase
your project and what that means though
is that anybody is working on a separate
branch will not be able to branch their
code back into the mainline branch so go
through the process of a git rebase
essentially allows you to create a new
start for where you're working on your
project so let's go through Forks and
clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and fork
the code that you're working on so this
user scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate Fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
like to go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you get to go and you can
take the version of the mainline branch
but then you take it completely offline
into a local repository for you to be
able to work from and you can take the
mainline code and you can then work on a
local version of the code separate from
the mainline branch is now a separate
Fork collaborators is the ability to
have team members working on a project
together so if you know someone is
working on a piece of code and they see
some errors in the code that you've
created none of us are perfect at
writing code I know I've suddenly made
errors in my code it's great have other
team members that have your bag and can
come in and check and see what they can
do to improve the code so to do that you
have to then add them as a collaborator
now you do that and get help you can
give them permission within github
itself it's really easy to super visual
interface that allows you to do the work
quickly and easily and depending on the
type of permissions you want to give
them sometimes it can be very limited
permissions it may be just to be able to
read the files sometimes it's being able
to go in and make all the changes you
can go through all the different
permission settings on github to
actually see what you can do but you'll
be able to make changes so that people
can actually have
access to your repository and then you
as a team can then start working
together on the same code let's step
through branching in git
so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a DevOps environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then divert your feature and then merge
it back into the master branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen show
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
there can be many branches and get so
get keeps you up the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process so you're
starting with the master branch which is
the blue line here and then here we have
a separate parallel branch which has the
new features so if we're to look at this
process the base commit of feature B is
the branch F is what's going to merge
back into the master branch and it has
to be said there can be so many
divergent branches but eventually you
want to have everything merge back into
the master branch it's step through git
rebase
so again we have a summer situation
where we have a branch that's being
worked parallel to the master branch and
we want to do a get rebase so we're at
stage C and what we've decided is that
we want to reset the project so that
everything from here on out with along
the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate branch will be adding in new
features along this new reap
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebate process is that
you're reducing the amount of storage
space that's required for when you have
so many branches it's a great way to
just reduce the your total footprint for
your entire project so get rebates is
the process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase it you unplug a branch and re
plug it in on the tip of another branch
and usually you do that on the master
branch and that will then become the new
master branch
the goal of rebasing is to take all the
commits from a feature branch and put it
together in a single master branch it
makes it the project itself much easier
to manage let's talk a little bit about
pull from remote so first our two
developers working together on
application the concept of having a
remote repository allows the code to the
two developers will be actually them
checking in their code into a remote
repository that becomes a centralized
location for them to be able to store
their code it enables them to stay
updated on the recent changes to the
repository because they'll be able to
pull the latest changes from that remote
repository so that they are ensuring
that as developers are always working on
the latest code so you can pull any
changes that you have made your fourth
remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in git soak it and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive get add adds one or more
files to your staging area git commit
dash em commit message is a commit
changes the git command commits changes
to head up so the git command commits
changes to your local staging area
get status checks the status of your
current repository and this the files
you have changed get block provides a
list of all the commits made on your
current branch get DIF user changes
you've made to the file so you can
achieve have files next to each other
you can actually see the differences
between the two files I get push origin
branch name so the name of your branch
command will push the branch to the
remote repository so that others can use
it and this is what you do at the end of
your project get config - global
username will tell get who you are by
configuring the author name and we'll go
through that in a moment
get config global user email will tell
git the author of by the email ID get
cloned creates a git repository copy
from a remote source get remote add
origin server connects the local
repository to the remote server and adds
the server to be able to push to it get
branch and then the branch name we'll
create a new branch for you to create a
new feature that you may be working on
and get checkout and then the branch
name will allow you to switch from one
branch to another branch get merge
branch name will merge a branch into the
active branch so if you're working on a
new feature you'll emerge that into the
main branch I get rebates will reapply
commits on top on another base tip and
get rebates will reapply commits on top
of another base tip and these are just
some of the popular git commands there
are some more but you can certainly dig
into those as you're working through
using git so let's go ahead and run a
demo using get so now we are going to do
a demo using get on our local machine
and github as the remote repository for
this to work I'm going to be using a
couple of tools first I'll have the deck
open as we've been using up to this
point the second is I'm going to have my
terminal window also available and let
me bring that over so you can actually
see this and the terminal window is
actually running git bash as the
software in the background which you'll
need to download and install in also run
git bash locally on your Windows
computer as well and in addition I'll
also have the github repository that we
using
simply learn I already set up and ready
to go alright so let's get started so
the first thing we want to do is create
a local repository so let's go ahead and
do exactly that so the local repository
is going to reside in my development
folder that I have on my local computer
and for me to be able to do that I need
to create a drive in that folder so I'm
going to go ahead and change the
directory so I'm actually going to be in
that folder before I actually create to
make the new folder so I'm going to go
ahead and change directory and now I'm
in the development directory I'm going
to go ahead and create a new folder and
that's going to head and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that
emoji in the hello world folder and now
that I'm in the hello world folder I can
now initialize this folder as a git
repository and we'll use the git command
in it to initialize and let's come ahead
and initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my hello
wall folder that I've created and you'll
now see that we have a hidden folder in
there which is called dot git and we
expand that we can actually see all of
the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so that we
can see the rest of the work and now if
we check on our folder here we actually
see this is users Mathew development
HelloWorld dot git and that matches up
with hidden folder here so we're going
to go ahead and create a file called
readme.txt in our folder so here is our
HelloWorld folder and I'm going to go
ahead and using my text editor which
happens to be sublime I'm going to
create a file and it's gonna have in
there text hello world and I'm gonna
call this one readme dot txt but I go to
my hello world folder you'll see that we
have the readme.txt file actually in the
folder what's interesting is if I select
the get status command what it'll
actually show me is that this file has
not yet been added to the commits yet
for this project so even though the file
is actually in the folder it doesn't
mean that it's actually part of the
project for us to do that we actually
have to go and select
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the git status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and usually get status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders have been committed
and what we can now do is we can go and
actually add the readme file so let's go
ahead one sec at git add so the git
command is add readme dot txt
so that then adds that file into our
main project and we want to then commit
those files into the main repositories
history and so does that do that we'll
have the get command commit and we'll do
a message in that commit and this one
will be first commit and it has
committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get get is a very popular
version control solution and we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme.txt so to do
that we'll use the diff command forget
so we do git diff and it gives us two
bad releases the first is what the
original text was which is hello world
and then what we have afterwards is what
is now the new text in green which is
replace the original text so what we can
do now is you want to go ahead and
create an account on github we already
have one and so what we're going to do
is we're going to match the account from
github with our local account so to do
that we're going to go ahead and say get
config and we're going to do - and it's
going to be a global user dot name and
we put in our username that we use for
github and this instance we're using the
simply learn - github account name and I
get hyper account you can go ahead and
create a new repository name in this
instance we called the repository hello
- world and what we want to do is
connect the local github account with
the remote hello world get account and
we do that by using this command from
get which is our remote connection and
so let's go ahead and type that in open
this up so we can see the whole thing so
we can type in git remote add origin
HTTP access back slash github.com slash
simply learn
- github and you have to get this type
incorrectly when you're typing in the
location hello - world dot get that
creates the connection to your hello
world account and now we want to do is
we want to push the files to the remote
location using the git push command
commit get push origin master so we're
going to
connect to a local remote github so I'm
just gonna bring up my terminal window
again and I said that select git remote
add origin and we'll connect to the
remote location github.com slash simply
learn - github slash hello - world don't
get oh we actually have already
connected so we're connected to that
successfully and now we're going to push
the master gish so get push origin
master and everything is connected and
successful and if we go out to github
now we can actually see that our file
was updated just a few minutes ago
so what can actually do now is we can go
and fork a project from github and clone
it locally so we're going to use this
fork tool that's actually available on
github let me show you where that is
located
and here is our branching torse actually
changed more recently with a new UI
interface and once the complete we'll be
able to then pull a copy of that to our
accounts using the forks new HTTP URL
address so let's go ahead and do that
you
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
four options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually for the project as I'm
working on the main branch however if I
come in with a separate idea Here I am I
have a different ID and so I'm actually
pretending I'm somebody else I can
actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork and there we
are we have gone ahead and created the
fork so you want to say clone or
download with this and so this is the
isolate that you give me the web address
I can actually show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor just
that's the great
I guess that is correct so I'm gonna
copy that
and I can fork the project locally and
clone it locally I can change the
directory so I can create a new
directory that I'm gonna put my files in
and then post in that content into that
folder so I can now actually have
multiple versions of the same code
running on my computer I can then go
into the forked content and use the
patchwork command to edgy so I can
create a copy of that code that we've
just created from a college that's a
clone and we can create a new folder
that we're actually putting the work in
and we could for whatever reason we
wants to we call this where for a
patchwork and that would be maybe a new
feature and then we can then paste in
the URL of the new directory though it
has the forked work in it and now at
this point we've now pulled in and
created a clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then divert
our work separately so now what we can
actually do is we can actually create a
branch of the fork that we've actually
pulled in onto our computer so we can
actually then create our own code that
runs in that separate branch and so we
want to check out I'm the the branch and
then push the origin branch down to our
computer this will give us the
opportunities then add our collaborators
so we can actually then go over to
github and we can actually come in and
add in our collaborators
and we will do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added by and fire
their github name or by email address or
by their full name one of the things
that you want to be able to do is ensure
that you're always keeping the code that
you're working on fully up-to-date by
pulling in all the changes from your
collaborators you can create a new
branch and then make changes emerge it
into the master branch but to do that
you would create a folder and then that
folder in this instance would be called
test we would then move our cursor into
the folder called test and then
initialize that folder so let's go ahead
and do that so that's cool create a new
folder and we're going to first of all
change our root folder and we're going
to go to development and I'm going to
create a new folder I call it test I'm
going to move into the test folder and
we will initialize that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
you
cause one test one and then we're gonna
do a file save as and this one's going
to be test2 and now we're going to
commit those files add that kit add and
then we'll use the dot to pull in all
files and then git commit dash and
make sure I'm in the right folder here
and I think I was and now that I'm in
the crack folder let's go ahead and and
git commit and it's gone ahead and edit
those files and so we can see the two
files that were created I've been added
into the master and we can now go ahead
and create a new branch you call this
one git branch test under school branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder this is file
3 to file save as we'll call this one
test it's read text and we'll go ahead
and add that file to get add test 3 dot
txt
and we're going to move from the master
branch to the test round branch get
check out test underscore branch I
switched to the test branch and we be
able to list out all of the files that
are in the teton that branch now and we
want to go through and merge the files
into one area so let's go ahead and
we'll do the git merge test underscore
branch nice well we've already updated
everything so that's good so otherwise
it would I tell us what we would be
merging and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go
Oh merge together fantastic and so what
we're going to do now is move from
master branch to test branch so git
checkout test underscore branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out and pull that file
up and we can now what I find and we can
then commit that file back in now we've
actually beyond so then commit the file
with one changes and since the text we
change that was made now we can now go
through a process of checking the file
back in switching back to the master
branch and ensuring that everything is
in sync correctly we may at one point
want to rebase all the work is kind of a
hard thing you want to do but it will
allow you to allow for managing for
changes in the future so let's switch to
it back to our test branch which I think
we're actually on we're going to create
two more files let's go to our folder
here and let's go copy those and that's
created we'll rename those tests 4 and 5
and so we now have additional files and
we
add those into our branch that we're
working on so we're going to go in state
get add - a and we're going to commit
those files git commit - a - M adding
two new files and it's added in the two
new files so we have all of our files
now we can actually list them out and we
have all the files that are in the
branch and we will switch them to our
master branch we want to rebase the
master so we do git rebase master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date we can go get checkout master to
switch to the master account that's what
I was to then continue through and
rebase the test branch and then list all
the files that are all in the same area
so let's go get rebase test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
hello and welcome to good commands my
name is chad anand and i am with this
simply learn team today i'm gonna cover
a few essential git commands and walk
you through a demonstration for most of
it i begin by installing a git bash on
the git client and configuring it for
its first time usage once I'm done with
configuring the git client I'm gonna
spin up few repositories locally and
work on these repositories using git
commands once I'm happy with my local
changes I'm gonna commit few of them and
then push these changes to a git server
of my choice for today's demonstration I
plan to use github comm which is a cloud
hosted free service and it provides free
account registrations for anyone
eventually I will cover few topics
regarding get branching and merging
because these two in my opinion are the
killer features of the get distributed
version control tool it is one of the
most popular distributed version control
tools of recent times and like any other
distributed version control tool it
allows us to perform various version
control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demonstration let me spend some time
explaining to you then get client-server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with get the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with git is something
called as git bash or the declined this
comes as an installer for all popular
operating systems like Windows all
flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
these repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user
also got get bash install on his system
this is where you would need something
called as a git server so for user one
or one user to share his repository with
another user he would need to
collaborate using something called as a
get server so in the present market
there are a bunch of get servers which
are popularly available some of them are
free some of them come with a cost
because they are licensed a bunch of
these servers that I can think of are
github which is one of the most popular
get service that is around in the market
for a long time now it comes with two
variants one is the cloud hosted one
which is the github calm and then the
other one is an enterprise server which
comes as a black box that can be
installed into your data centers so
typically organizations who don't want
their source code to be put up on the
cloud but go for this github enterprise
service we're in the buy this service
and these servers are hosted on their
data centers other popular variant of
the git server is big bucket this is
from the famous Atlas Ian products and
it integrates very well with all other
Atlas in products like JIRA in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called git lab which is
getting very very popular these days
because git lab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code checking
that is going in you have this runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and get lab also
provides you with the community edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github comm by providing
my username and my password and I'm
going to use a free account
so whatever repositories that I'm gonna
put up on this server is all public by
default so I will register myself by
using my username or my email ID and my
password so this set of authentication
is also referred to as HTTP
authentication so in order for me to
share my repository with say use
- the first thing that I got to do was
have an access to a git server where
both user 1 and user 2 are set up so
once I have that I can push my
repository on to this server and provide
right kind of access so that user 2 or
the other developer who wishes to
collaborate with me on this repository
can use his credentials as long as his
resister properly on the git server he
can use his credentials and pull down
this repository and work with this
repository so this is the HTTP way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called less ssh authentication as
many of you would know this is such
means nothing but creation of a private
and a public key a bunch of keys public
and private are created on the client
machine while one create a piece I will
be asked for a passphrase I need to type
in a pass phrase and remember my
passphrase and then I take this public
key and kind of post it on to my account
within my kit server so that whenever
I'm gonna connect next time using my
command prompt or any of the tools it's
going to challenge me for my pass phrase
as long as I remember my pass phrase
correctly I can authenticate myself and
get into the server so both HTTP and SSH
are popular ways of communicating with
the it server having said this let me
just get started by installing the git
bash on my local system and then fire up
some of these git commands and build up
some repositories make some changes in
my repository come in these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there let me now go
ahead and find my git bash for my
windows so that I can go ahead and
install it so I just type in get client
for Windows open up a browser and type
in for this the first one that I find
has a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
blind I need this one so this is the get
kind or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Meg's and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
come
when I'm recording this video the
version that I have the latest version
that is there is two or 19.0 and this is
a 64-bit version for Windows so got that
downloaded let me go ahead and find it
and install this Exe all right I go
ahead choosing all the default options I
want it to be installed in C colon
program files under the git folder
everything looks good for me I'm not
going to make any changes here git bash
from windows yes and I want to use git
from Windows command prompt that sounds
good for me
OpenSSH that's fine
looks good looks good and I don't want
any of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the gate
bash or the gate client so that I can
start using my bit commands the version
that I'm using is to dot 19.0 which as I
record this video this happens to be the
latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say a
landscape - so what I get is this window
so this is the gate command prompt so
let me check if everything is looking
good say gate to ocean it sounds good
say gate hell all right a lot of get
help commands everything looks good so I
ended up installing the gate bash I can
go ahead with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
user name and the email ID with which I
want the gate bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config - -
global which means that this setting
that I'm gonna set would be a global
setting user dot name and this the name
of the user who needs to be specified
within a double curve in my case I am
using a simpler account this is the
official account and this is the
particular user name of this account the
other setting is nothing but git config
- - global this is also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
not contain a double coat so in my case
this is the email ID that I would be
setting up get to work with all right
let me check if the configurations were
set correctly or not
all right if you see this a user name
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
get prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm gonna create all my multiple
git repositories so I would create a
folder called let's say git underscore
demo all right this already a folder
called get demo so let me just delete
that in the first place and let me
create this get demo again all right let
me navigate to this particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
the SIS demo so this would be a folder
said I would use this folder as a base
folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first depository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me read my first folder called first
repo and let me get into the syllable
alright as of now this is just an empty
folder if at all I navigate to this
you'll see that this folder is empty
there's nothing much in this folder at
all at this moment okay so let me create
a repository out of this how do I create
a repository of this is pretty simple I
just run and get in it command when I
say get in it it means it's gonna
initialize a repository as of now the
folder contain nothing in it was an
empty repository so it initially is an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all I look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I
have configured my Explorer to view all
hidden food as I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
kit is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command get in it if I get into this
folder I see a bunch of directories and
other configurations if you see there's
something called as a hooks directory a
couple of configuration files that are
here in this territory all these relate
to one or the other type of a client
hook that can be enabled and there's
info this objects this reference is a
bunch of stuff that is there so what is
this folder this is a magical git folder
and this is created whenever a
repositories initialized so by default
if at all you get into any git folder or
any git repository you would see this
dot git folder a word of caution do not
get into this folder and try to modify
anything because if you Fiddler on with
this and corrupt this particular folder
your whole repository will go for a toss
so let me come out of this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say get in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder and whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with a
git init and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder little you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch master
no text and open up in the notepad okay
so this is my first file that's what I'm
going to write inside this
this and it come out of this all right
now let me do a git status command so
what does this tell you there's no
commit set you're on the master branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in Fred it also gives you all
the command that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say git add and the name of
the file and then you're gonna commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that I get notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master dot text if at
all you want you want us to let get know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it is there's no committee yet
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master dot text all
right it also gives you something called
git remove command if at all you want to
unstaged or undo your changes so what
has happened is the file which was
earlier on track it's been added into
the get index or it is ready for staging
or it's in the staged state now I can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what I want to do so let me do
that I'll do a git commit - em and they
give a message that I want I would say
this is my first gate commit
all right I run the gate status command
again and see it says on the branch
master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean typically what happened was I
created the empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a get in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if at all
I run the git log command it says this
was the commit ID or the commit number
or the commit hash tag and this is the
author if you notice this is the email
ID and the username that was set earlier
and this was done on this date and this
is the commit message that is there all
of it looks so good let me do one more
commit into this repository so I will
touch master one dot text I'll put in
another file I'll open up this
particular file
right something into those
all right I save this change let me also
open up the older file make some more
change into this alright so what I did I
modified the older file that existed I
also added a new file to my repository
now if I run the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which was an untracked file
alright now let me add both these files
because these are the changes that I
want to incorporate I would say git add
dot right on the git status command
again and it says now this is a modified
find this is a new file looks good to me
let me go ahead and commit this so gate
commit with a message that says this is
my second commit all right if I do get
log now it shows boot the commits the
first commit is the one that shows up at
the bottom and the topmost one is the
latest commit that is there so far so
good if at all you notice I'm doing all
these git commands without really
connected it to any git server I don't
need any network connection for doing
any of these things I can keep on doing
more and more git commands and run git
commands the way I want to without
really having any connections to the kit
server now that I have my changes the
way I wanted and I've checked in all the
code changes into my local repository I
may want to share my repository with
somebody else and work in a
collaborative way so the way to do that
is as I mentioned earlier to host this
repository or to push this repository
onto a git server I already have a
github account wherein have registered
myself using my username and password
so I log in to my github account using
my username and credentials and let me
go ahead and create a new repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server if you notice
the name of my repository is his first
repo so let me copy this I would create
a folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it would go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
gate hub repository on the server this
is just an optional description that
will show up and if you notice I can't
have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just the
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
on to the server and also important
point it shows me two URLs
one is the HTTP URL and the other one is
the SSH URL as of now we do not have any
SSH keys that is setup so let me use
this HTTPS URL to connect my local
repository with the repository on the
server so I've done all these things I
already have the repository set up all
that I need is a place holder for me to
connect my local repository with the
server URL so this would be the command
that I need to copy which essentially
links or adds an origin with the URL of
the git server I just copy this command
and run it here get remote add the name
of the remote is called origin and it
points to an HTTP URL which is nothing
but the placeholder that I've created on
the server alright so let me check if
it's added correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two commits in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is get push - you this is for
linking the upstream
origin/master so gate push - you
upstream linking origin master link the
master branch of my local repository
with the master branch on the server
repository and where is it going to push
it is going to push by default to an
origin and the origin points to this URL
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up on URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log in to my github server so let me
just copy and paste the username and the
password with which average is still
I will say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called master it has linked the
master branch from the local repository
with the master branch on this server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot txt if at all I
see the Comets they seem to be two
comets this is my first commit this is
my second commit and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was line that was
added if you look at the second commit
I added these lines I made this you know
one line chain that was there I also
added this new file which was not
existing these are the two commits that
existed and if you see the timestamp of
the commit this is the commit which was
committed for 15 minutes ago
so what does this mean is that the
commit is the timestamp when we actually
committed the code in the client the
pushing is just after we committed the
change we have pushed it so there's no
time stamp of the push that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial we're in I created repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating her repository
skeleton on the server now let me
demonstrate to you the SSH configuration
that is required for creating a pair of
SSH keys and ensuring that I connect to
the github server using the SSH
mechanism for doing that I need to first
create a pair of private and public key
the command to do that is ssh-keygen
- tea I will use the RSA mechanism for
creating my keys capital C and I need to
specify the email ID using which I'm
going to connect to all right I need to
create the keys for all right so
generating a private and public key pair
it says let me know what folder should I
create the keys in so by default the
keys are created in the user home
directory under a dot SSH folder so this
is pretty good for me so let me go ahead
and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase keep in mind that I would
need to remember my pass phrase because
when I am going to authenticate myself
using SSH mechanism it will challenge me
for this particular passphrase I need to
enter the right pass phrase so that I
get authenticated so the key is
generated and by default it is created
in this particular folder so let me go
over to that particular folder
can this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copied the contents of the
whole file
and now I would need to stick it in on
the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I've
logged in to get up using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and GPG keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or GPG keys so I would click
on new assisted key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say Paris SH key it prompts me for my
password just to make sure that
the right kind of authentication to be
adding a new key so this one looks good
that means the keys were added
successfully let me check if my SSH keys
are working well
so I do as a search - capital T I would
say get at github.com this is just to
double check if my SSH keys are
authenticated correctly are you sure you
want the connection yes you want to
continue yes all right now a check for
my passphrase let me enter my password I
hope I remember it correctly
alright triggered I have been
successfully authenticated so that means
now my sis H keys are good and just by
using my passphrase I can connect to my
github server using SSH
alright so for the second use case what
I would do is create a repository on the
server with some content in it and then
clone that repository cloning is nothing
but making a copy of that repository
linking the origin so that I create an
exact replica of the repository which is
there on the server on my local drive so
let me first create a repository on the
server I will create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo give some description this is my
second repo
that is created two straight on the gets
over on the github server to be precise
it's a public repository this time I'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server alright I say
create a repository
so a random readme file with some
content in it gets created and I can see
there are two URLs to this repository
HTTP and SSH so this time let me copy
the ssh URL so that I will use this URL
to clone this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
alright so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second report that I
created on the server the command to do
that is get clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone oops
looks like a heading
copy the URL correctly copy that again
copy this URL alright so if you notice
there is no HTTP to it
I'm just cloning the URL that is SSH URL
of the repository
it asked for my pass phrase again
okay so I just had first deposited
earlier now I have something called a
second report this is an exact replica
of whatever was the repository content
that was created on the server so if I
get into the repository there's just the
simple readme file that is there let me
try to add a new file out here I would
say not bad
second or text some text file I'm gonna
put in here yes definitely you will not
find that file there
this is my second
file that I will push on to the server
I'm gonna put in some content out there
I'll save this and if I don't get status
it says this this is a new contract file
do you want to add this file on to the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file
let me also commit my change to the file
with a message this is my first commit
for this second repo
forgiving some particular message
and this time around since I clone my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin in all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
around on the server which is why I had
to set up the upstream branches and
stuff like that in this case I have
cloned an existing repository from the
server so when I clone I get the replica
along with all references to my
repository so I don't need to do
anything more I then push the content I
was just saying it push to be in the
safe aside I would say origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay post the
servers let me see in the condenser
coming here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second commit so
what was added as a part of the second
commit it says a new file was added all
this line that never existed got added
this is the second file the content
exactly what I pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when I
created repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH a
quick recap of all the git commands that
we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all
you're creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a good repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folders by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master branch
and git add dot is a wildcard character
for adding any number of new files into
your and get repository if you have a
bunch of files one file to file 10 files
a folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository done
with that you want to commit the changes
that has happened in the repository you
use the git commit command git commit -
M with a meaningful message this will
commit all the work items that you've
done in terms of the files that got
changed the more files that got added
all this with one particular message git
status we give you the status of all the
files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all the status of the
files will be obtained using thing get
status command git log will show you all
the commit history with the latest
history or the latest commits showing up
on top git add remote origin this
command is used whenever
want to link any local repository to a
server and this is when you want to
really push a repository from the local
to the server for the first time git
push - you
origin and master this is the command
that you would use whenever you want to
push contents from the local repository
to the server git clone and the URL of
the server this is the command that you
will run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box more than often many
developers or get users find themselves
in situations where they would want to
go back in history and modify or change
some of the files that they recently
committed or checked into the repository
now from a perspective of gate this is a
very very simple activity however
respect to your version control tool you
will have to be really cautious about
the chain that you're gonna do in case
the changes are pretty local none of the
developers or none of the other users
who are collaborating with you would be
affected by this change
you're good to go ahead and make this
change however if your repository has
been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users will be
using it you need to be really cautious
while running these commands in case
your repository contains are local if
you've not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you miss few things you can go ahead and
modify this with some of these commands
let's say I have this simple repository
called undo undo repo and if at all I
look at the logs of these I have the
committee's trees which are like this I
have about 5 commits that is there in my
repository and in c1 added a file in c2
our and the file in c3 I've also added
some file in c4 I made some changes to M
1 and M 3 and in C 5 have added another
file called M 4
now this is my commit history now let's
say I made these two commits but
possibly I want to Club them together
along with some other changes because
whatever changes I did did not really
fix things the way I expected
to fix so there is a good command called
git reset this would allow me to go back
in history to go back to any of the
snapshot get rid of all this commit
history on the coming messages but
retain the changes that were made as a
part of these comments so if at all I
need to go back in history and go back
to this particular commit and however I
just want to get rid of these commits
that are there in terms of the commit
messages but I want the changes that
were there as a part of these commits to
still exist I would do command called
git reset - - soft now this would go
back or unwind my changes back to this
particular snapshot getting rid of all
the commit messages that were there as a
part of these two commits but a soft
would ensure that the final changes that
were done as a part of these two commits
would still exist a full remain so the
command for that is git reset - - soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the commit that I
want to get back to I just copy this and
paste this alright it doesn't give me
any message but if at all I do a good
log pretty one-line what it says is c1
c2 now the head which is nothing but the
current pointer which was earlier
pointing to c5 it's gone back to c3 now
what happened to the changes that were
there as a part of c4 and c5 if at all
you do a git status if you see the
changes that were a part of c4 was some
changes to m1 and m2 and see if I a new
file got m4 got added if at all do a git
status you'd see those changes still
exist however from the get history or
the get commit history c3 is the topmost
commit that exists as of now c4 and c5
having gotten rid of but the changes
that were there still exist
alright now I can
make some more changes that I want if as
a part of my commit and possibly go
ahead and commit this whole thing as a
new commit altogether maybe I'll open up
a notepad and possibly create a new file
called m6 dot text and say one new file
that was missed out I make this change I
go to a get status all these files are
still there I would say git add dot I
was a good comic - mc4 free writing
history
and I do a good
love-30 there you go so c1 c2 c3 still
existed and whatever was a part of c4
and c5 the older ones I've gotten rid of
this along with those old changes I also
added a new file I made some changes and
it was able to commit it now if I look
at my gate history it's all nice and
clean however do this activity only when
in don't push your git repository to the
server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as a revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and has not been pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a good server
and I have the changes which are c1 c2
c3 and possibly c4 all right so this is
a bunch of comics that has happened this
was the oldest commit and this is the
newest commit and if at all developer
one is the one who's responsible for
pushing these contents in the first
place so he has got c1 to c4 on his
history and I'm going to jump all this
c2 and c3 and carry to c4 and he's
pushed all this contents out here and
there are a bunch of people from the
server was pulled this repository and
all of them are the same level now
imagine a use case where developer one
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these commits
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something what would happen to all these
people who are looking to work ahead
from c4 all of them would be affected in
an adverse way so in short never go back
in history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
commit to undo something let's take this
example maybe if at all a developer one
wants to get rid of c3
way to do that is by adding a new commit
which is ahead say let's say C Phi and
what does this come into this come it
possibly gets rid of the c3 instead of
going back in history it actually is
taking your get history I had but as a
part of this commit you're undoing some
part of the work that was done as a part
of c3 in short you're removing a commit
but to remove a commit you're adding a
new commit and this is why you're doing
it because there are a bunch of other
people who were your whose is this
repository collaboratively and worked
plan to get ahead in terms of history
they cannot afford to go back in history
and modify something in history alright
the command to do this is called the git
revert command so let me take up this
repository which has got a bunch of
commits in it and if at all I don't get
to log 14 one-line I have these bunch of
comments
and see one I've added a file in situ
our another file in c3 have added one
more file and in c4 I made some changes
and this is the latest commit and this
is the oldest commit so if at all I see
the contents of the git folder
it contains M 1 M 2 M 3 and M 4 and
let's see
looking at the previous use case that I
mentioned I may want to get rid of this
particular commit I want to get rid of
the c3 which is nothing but I've added a
file called m3 dot txt but I added it by
mistake I need a better way of fixing it
possibly I look at it later on but for
now I don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the get revert
command so get revert and the commit ID
whatever I want to revert so if you want
to revert this I copied this particular
commit ID and bear in mind that
considering reset revert works on one
commit at a time so I can do one commit
revert at a time I can club a bunch of
them together and do one commit but
otherwise the revert always works on one
commit at a time so get revert face this
essentially what I am trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular coming
while I'm undoing this commit what does
get do it safely adds a new commit and
the part of this new commit it undoes
whatever changes that were done as a
part of this commit so if I say git
revert this all right I forgot to
mention the message which is why this
window showing up but that message is
good for me I say right and quit all
right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this Sivan still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from CFI I see another
commit but what was there as a part of
this commit actually is getting rid of
this come at c3 so if at all I see my
files here there's only M 1 M 2 and M 4
M 3 was added as a part of c3 now I've
gotten rid of M 3 by getting rid of the
revert command for c3 so this is a
better way of undoing things now that we
have acquainted ourselves with few of
those basic read commands let me get
into a very very interesting topic
regarding gate which is about branching
the topic is interesting because it
deals with branches in a completely
different way compared to any other
version control tool in most of the
version control tools whenever you
create a new branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it is a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space
however in Gate you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive in great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that so let me go
back to my base directory which is gate
demo and then I'm going to create a new
folder here I'll create a folder called
org details correct
this is my folder here all right I
navigate into this folder and let me
create a repository here I initialize a
repository and dot git folder is created
without any files in it so let me create
a few files in it say notepad name dot
txt
organization name I create a named or
text within this
maybe I'll create one more file in this
notepad employs dot text simply love has
over three key employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content alright so if a tour I do
get status I just see two files in it so
let me go ahead and add these two files
and let me commit my changes okay
commit - a.m. or - em
first coming
cific do a gig log I see only one commit
and there are two files and you can see
those two files that is here all right
so at this stage let me go ahead and
create a new branch and the command for
creating new branches get branch name of
the branch so let me name my Prime's has
been rule branch BL our branch and this
created a branch but I don't see any
changes in the folder structure or in
the file that exists here I've just
created this branch so if a tour I do a
git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
branch so let me go ahead and get into
the BLR branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same
there's absolutely no change in any of
the branches both master and Baylor
branch onto the same snapshot so let me
get into the other branch and the
command to do that is gate check out BL
our branch now actually switched in to
handle branch if you see the content of
the files this exactly two files the way
it was earlier because I created a
branch from my base branch which is a
master branch and when I created a
branch there were two files existing
here if you see the content of these
files they would all be the same all
right so let me create a fine that is
specific to Bangalore branch so I would
just say notepad maybe I want to put
down the address of this organization
specific to Bangalore in this address
dot txt
so I say notepad address dot text also
simply learn Bangalore office located in
some atras I would say pannier that is
the content of this file and I am
creating all this new file in this BLR
branch so I'm saying it add dot and also
git commit - M Bangalore branch commit
all right if
see this now I have an address not text
which is there only in the manual branch
but I'm presently on now let me switch
back to my master branch the command to
do that is gate check out master branch
if you remember when they folk doubt or
when I created a new branch from the
master branch I didn't have this
addressed or text in it so let me go
back to get did check out master branch
and keep noticing this particulars what
happened to the address dot text it kind
of disappeared how did that happen so
all because of this magical git folder
so what happened is now git knows that
veneer in the master branch the file
that was there in the Bengal branch
which was called Lee I just thought text
didn't exist so git is playing around
with the file system snapshot so if I
come back let's say I come back to get
check out bangle branch if you see this
the address dot txt file appears so this
particular file is only present in the
branch and gate is playing around with
the file system snapshot by moving the
pointer across and ensuring that
whenever I'm switching to Bangalore
branch I see this address dot txt when I
go back to my master branch I don't say
this manual branch contents which is the
address dot next
alright now that I created this branch
maybe I may need to push this on to the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in a
previous exercise so the name of the
folder needs to be exactly this one so
let me copy this and let me create a
repository very quickly go here and say
new repository correctly this is the
name of the repository get France demo
this what I'm gonna put it as a
description I would say public I don't
want any readme files in it because I
already have a repository I will just
say create a repository alright let me
use the ASIS actually this is this is HR
and this is good for me so let me copy
this URL let me add it here I'm linking
my local repository with the server and
I would let me come back to my master
branch
let me first push my master branch so I
would say gate push - you origin master
it asks for my passphrase alright I
pushed my master branch it looks good
it's his new bunch must just created so
if I go back to my server and I do a
refresh if you see it says only one
branch and it says what is the name of
the branch master if you see the
contents that is employees door text and
name dot text now let's try to push the
other branch that is there the command
to do that is a little different
compared to the way we created it on the
trying because on the client we created
the branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new branch or to
the server so the command would be
Gate push - new origin in the name of
the brand that I want to specifically
push all right now
it created a branch out here they module
refresh of this all right
it's his two branches if I can into this
Bandra branch I would see the address
dot text if at all I can go back into
master branch I would not see this
address dot text wonderful now let me do
one thing let me try to get the changes
from the branch that I created
back into the master branch that is what
I would mean by merging I would want the
changes that is there as a part of the
Bengal branch to come back into my
master branch so if I go to take check
out back new branch I see this attention
attack this is there only as a part of
Bengal branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Vandal
branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back to my
master branch and the way to merge in
the changes sees get merge so what is
that you want to merge I want to merge
the Bengal branch changes and where will
it much it will merge it into the
current branch that I'm on presently I
am in the master branch so this command
would merge the changes from the Bengal
branch into your master branch so with
this if we keep looking here the content
that was there that was added as a part
of bamboo branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do one much alright
so it happened quickly and he would see
this address dot text that is here so if
you see let's check the contents in
terms of the big log all right so there
was only one branch that we had earlier
which had only one commit right now we
read this Bangla branch commit which was
there as a part of the Bengal branch
commit
so with this change let me push this
change on to the server as well get push
origin master right those changes were
pushed to the server and now if at all I
do all the fresh out here okay I mean
two branches the princess's master even
if I meant master Prince I should see
this address dot text that is there even
if I am in the mangrove bench the
content is all shame because we immerse
these two branches now that I've merged
this branch I don't need this branch
anymore so I would go ahead and delete
this locally as well as push it on to
the server so that it gets deleted from
the server as well so delete branch
locally the command is getting branch -
D and the name of the branch only thing
you need to ensure is that you should
not be currently on that branch which
are trying to delete so I would say get
branch and I'm presently in the master
branch so I can go ahead and delete the
other branch so get branch - D manual
branch
alright this got rid of our Pender
branch locally
if at all I don't get branch - we it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this branch would still exist on
the server because server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server okay - brands
are still here so let me go it and push
this changes so that the branch gets
deleted from the server as well the
command to do that is get push origin -
- delete and the name of the branch
all right so this went ahead and deleted
the branch from this server let's check
that okay if you see now there's only
one branch these are the basic steps
that you would need to know before you
work with any of the branches within get
and as I said before the branches are
very very inexpensive indeed go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you want but just ensure that once you
create your branch finish off your task
and once you finish off your task go
ahead and deed the branch and before you
delete the branch please ensure that you
merge in the branches so that you get in
or take in the work that was done as a
part of that particular branch to
summarize the get branching commands are
as follows to create a new branch you
issue a command gate branch in the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issued this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command get to branch a new
underscore branch it creates a new
underscore branch from the master branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this branch you would type in
it check out the name of the branch this
would automatically switch the
filesystem snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command gate
push - new origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed on
to this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be gate branch
- AV assuming that you did all your work
in a new branch and you're happy with
the changes you would want to bring back
those changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contains that you specified into
the branch on which you currently recite
if at all you're on the master branch
and you feel sure command gate much new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
this branch locally is gate branch -
capital D in the name of the branch this
again would delete the branch locally in
order to make this change on the server
which is in order to remove this branch
from the server the command to do that
is get push origin - - dili and the name
of the branch
this would also delete the branch that
you created on the server we have almost
reached the end of the tutorial
finally we have picked some essential
get questions that you might face in any
DevOps interview so let's just get into
those general DevOps questions so one of
the questions that you're going to be
asked is how is DevOps different from
agile and the reality is is that DevOps
is a cultural way of being able to
deliver solutions that's different from
agile we look at the evolution of
delivery over the last five to ten years
we've gone from waterfall and based
delivery to agile delivery which is on
Sprint's to where we are with continuous
integration and continuous delivery
around DevOps the whole concept of
DevOps is culturally very very different
from agile and the difference is is that
you're looking at being able to do
continuous releases what does that mean
the difference is is that you want to be
able to send out code continuously to
your production environment that means
the operations team the development team
have to be working together that means
that any code that gets created has to
be able to go to production very quickly
which means you need to be testing your
code continuously and then that
production environment must also be able
to be tested continuously and any
changes or any errors that come up have
to be communicated effectively and
efficiently back to the dev and ops team
another area in which I see that DevOps
is different is really the response that
we have for how we engage with the
customer so the customer is coming to
your website to your mobile app
your chat BOTS or any digital solution
that you have and has an expectation
when you're going through and actually
doing a dev ops paradigm the old model
would be that you would capture
requirements from the customer then you
do your development then you do your
testing and there would be these
barriers between each of those as we
move faster through from waterfall to
agile what we saw is that with agile we
were able to respond much faster to
customer demands so instead of being
weeks or months sometimes in some cases
years between releases of software or we
saw it would was a transition to weeks
and months for releases on software now
we see with DevOps
is that the release cycle has shrunk
even further with the goal of
continuously delighting the customer how
further has that release cycle shrunk to
there are companies that have gone from
having releases of once a week or once
every two weeks or once a month to now
having multiple releases a day indeed
some companies have up to 50 releases a
day this isn't something to also bear in
mind is that each of those releases are
tested and verified against test records
so that you can guarantee that the code
that's going to production is going to
be good continuous code so what are the
differences between the different phases
of DevOps so effectively there are two
main phases of DevOps service the
planning and coding phase and then
there's the deploying phase and you have
a tool such as Jenkins that allows you
to integrate between both environments
some of the core benefits that you may
have to dev offs are going to be some
technical benefits and some business
benefit so if somebody asks you what are
the benefits of DevOps you can reply
that from a technical point of view
you're able to use continuous software
delivery to constantly push out code
that has been tested and verified
against scripts that have been written
and approved you can be able to push out
smaller chunks of code so that when you
have an issue you're not having to go
through massive blocks of code or
massive projects you go through just
very small micro services or
more sections of code and you're able to
detect and correct problems faster on
the business side the benefits are
absolutely fantastic from a customer
that's coming to your website and or to
your mobile app they're going to see
responses happening continuously so that
the customer is always aware that you as
a company are listening to their demands
and responding appropriately you're able
to provide a more stable environment and
you're able to scale that environment to
the demands of the number of customers
that are using your services so how are
you approach a project that needs to
implement DevOps
so this is really an exciting area for
you to be in so there are effectively
three stages when it comes to actually
working in a DevOps the first stage is
an assessment stage and think of this as
the back of the napkin ideation stage
this is where you are sitting with a
business leader and they're giving you
ideas of what they would like to see
from feedback that they've had from
their customers this is blue sky
opportunity this is thinking of big
ideas that second stage and this often
comes as a fast follow to stage one is
actually proving out that concept so
developing a proof of concept and a
proof of concept can actually be
multiple different things so it could be
something as simple as a wireframe or it
could be something that is as complex as
a mini version of the final application
depending on the scope of the work that
you're delivering it will really depend
on how complicated you want the POC to
be but with that in mind whatever choice
you make you have to be able to deliver
enough in the POC
so that when you present this to a
customer they're able to respond to that
creation that you've developed and able
to give you feedback to be able to
validate that you are going with the
right solution and able to provide the
right product to your customers that
third stage is where you get into your
dev Ops stage and this is just the
exciting part this is where the rubber
hits the road and you start releasing
code are based on a backlog of features
that
are being requested for the solution in
contrast to doing agile delivery where
you just continuously work through a
backlog with DevOps what you're also
looking at is putting in analytics and
sensors to be able to validate that you
are being successful with the solution
that being delivered so that once you've
actually start delivering out code that
customers can interact with you want to
be able to see what are the pieces of
the solution that they are using what do
they like what is complicated where are
the failure points and you want to use
that data and feed that back into your
continuous integration and have that as
a means to be able to backfill the
demand of work that gets completed in
the bank log so what is the difference
between continuous delivery and
continuous deployment so continuous
delivery is based on putting out code
that can be deployed safely to
production and ensures that your
businesses and functions are running as
you would expect them to be so it's
going through and completing the code
that you would actually see continuous
deployment in contrast is all about
ensuring that you are automating the
deployment of a production environment
so you're able to go through and scale
up your environments to meet the demands
of both the solution and the customer
this makes software development and
release processes much more faster and
more robust so if we look here we can
actually see where continuous
integration and continuous deployment
come hand-in-hand so when you actually
start out with the initial pushes of
your code that's where you're doing your
continuous integration and your
continuous delivery and then at some
point you want to get very comfortable
with deploying the code that you're
creating so it's being pushed out to
your production environments one of the
things that's great about working with
the tools that you use in a DevOps
continuous integration and continuous
delivery model is that the development
tools that you use the containerization
tools the testing tools should always
reflect the production environment and
what this means is that when you
actually come to deploy
solutions to production there are no
surprises because your development team
have been working against that exact
same environment all the way through so
a question that you'll also be asked is
you know what is the role of the
configuration management and dev ops and
so the role of configuration management
really has three distinct areas I'm the
first and this is really obvious one and
this is the one where you probably
already have significant experiences is
the ability manage and handle large
changes to multiple systems in seconds
rather than days hours or weeks as that
may have happened before the second area
is that you want to also demonstrate the
business reasons for having
configuration management and the
business reason here is that allows IT
and infrastructure to standardize on
resource configurations and this has a
benefit in that you're able to do more
with fewer people so instead of having a
large configuration team you can
actually have a smaller more highly
skilled team that's able to actually
manage an even larger operational
environment and thirdly you want to be
able to highlight the ability to scale
so if you have configuration management
tools you're able to merge a significant
number of servers and domains that may
have multiple servers and it allows you
to effectively manage servers that are
deployed on cloud or private cloud and
allow you to do this with high accuracy
so how does continuous monitoring help
and maintain the entire architecture of
the system so when this question comes
up you want to dig in and show your
knowledge on how configuration and
continuous monitoring is able to control
an entire environment so the number one
topic that you want to bring up when it
comes to continuous monitoring is that
worth being able to effectively monitor
your entire network 24/7 for any changes
as they happen you're able to identify
and report those faults or threats
immediately and respond immediately for
your entire
Network instead of having to wait as it
happens sometimes for a customer to
email or call you and say hey your
website's down nobody wants that that's
an embarrassing thing the other three
areas that you want to be able to
highlight are the ability to be able to
ensure that the right software and the
right services are running on the right
resources that's your number one
takeaway that you want to be able to
give of continuous monitoring the second
is to be able to monitor the status of
those servers continuously this is not
requiring manually monitoring but having
a agent that's monitoring those servers
continuously and then the third is that
by scripting out and continuously
monitoring your entire environment
you're creating a self audit trail that
you can take back and demonstrate the
effectiveness of the operations
environment that you are providing so
one of the cloud companies that is a
strong advocate for DevOps is Amazon's
Web Services AWS and they have really
five distinct areas that you can zero in
on board services so when the question
comes up what is the role of AWS in
DevOps and you want to really hold out
your hand and list of five areas of
focus using your thumb and finger so you
want to have flexible services built for
scale automation secure and a large
partner ecosystem and having those five
areas will really be able to help
demonstrate why you believe that AWS and
and other cloud providers but AWS r70
the leader in this space are great for
being able to provide support for the
role of DevOps
so one of the things that we want to be
able to do effectively when we're
releasing any kind of solution is to be
able to measure that solution and so
KPIs are very important so you will be
asked for three important dev of KPIs
and so three that really come to mind
that are very effective the first one is
mean time to failure recovery and what
this talks about is what is the average
time does it take to recover from a
failure and if you have experience doing
this then look at the experience you
have and use a specific example where
you were able to dem
straight that mean time to failure
recovery the second is deployment
frequency and with deployment frequency
you want to be able to discuss how often
do you actually deploy solutions and
what actually happens when you actually
doing those deployments and what does
the impacts to your network look like
when you're doing those deployments and
then the third one is really tied to
that deployment frequency which is
around what is the percentage of failed
deployments and so how many times did
you deploy to a server and something
happened where the server itself failed
what we're looking for when you're going
through and being asked for these KPIs
is experience with actually doing a
DevOps deployment and being able to
understand what DevOps looks like when
you're pushing out your infrastructure
and then the second is being able to
validate that self auditing ability and
one word of caution is don't go in there
and say that you have a hundred percent
success the reality is that servers do
degrade over time and you maybe want to
talk about a time when a server did
degrade in your environment and use that
as a story for how you were able to
successfully get over and solve that
degradation so one of the terms that is
very popular at the moment is
infrastructure as code and so you're
gonna be asked to explain infrastructure
as code and really it's it's something
that actually becomes a byproduct of the
work you have to do when you're actually
putting together your DevOps environment
and infrastructure as code really refers
to the writing of code to actually
manage your environment and you can go
through many of the other tools that
we've covered in this series but you'll
see that XML or Ruby or Yama are used as
languages to describe the configuration
for your environment this allows you to
then create the rules and instructions
that can be read by the machines that
are actually setting up the physical
Hardware versus a traditional model
which is having software and installing
a software directly onto the machine
this is really important when it comes
to cloud computing there really is a
strong emphasis of being able to explain
infrastructure as a service and
infrastructure as code is fundamental
to the foundation to infrastructure as
service and then finally allows you to
be able to talk about how you can use
scripted languages such as Yammer to be
able to create a consistent experience
for your entire network all right so
let's now get into the next section
which is source code management and
we're going to focus specifically on git
the reason being is that get is really
the most popular source code management
solution right now there are other
technologies out there but for the types
of distributed environments that we have
a source code management would get is
probably the most effective so the first
question you'll be asked when it comes
to get is to talk about the difference
between centralized and distributed
version control and if we look at the
way that the two are set older
technologies such as older versions of
Team Foundation server though the
current version does actually have get
in it but older versions required a
centralized server for you to check in a
check out of code the developer in the
centralized system does not have all the
files for the application and if the
centralized server crashes then you
actually lose all of the history of your
code now in contrast a distributed model
actually we do check in our code to a
server however for you to be effective
and building out your solution you
actually check out all of the code for
the solution directly on to your local
development machine so you can actually
have a copy of the entire solution
running on your local machine this
allows you to be able to work
effectively offline it really allows for
scalability when it comes to building
out your team so if you have a team and
that may be in Europe you can actually
then scale that team with people from
Asia from North America or South America
very easily and not have to worry about
whether or not they have the right code
of the wrong code and in addition to
that if the actual main server where
you're checking in your code does crash
it's not a big deal
because
you actually have each person has a copy
of the code so as soon as the server
comes back up you have to check back in
and everybody's running back as if there
was nothing had happened at all so one
of the questions you'll be asked is to
give the answer to some of the commands
you use for working with git so if you
were to be asked the question is what is
the git command that downloads any
repository from github to your computer
on the screen we have four options we
have get push get fork get clone and get
commit the answer in this instance would
be get clone now if you want to be able
to push code from your local system to
github repository using git then first
of all you want to be able to do is
connect the local prostitute or a remote
repository and in the example you may
want to talk about using the command git
remote add origin and then the actual
path to a github repository you could if
you want to actually at this point also
talk about other repositories such as
get lab that you can also work with or a
private git repository that would be
used just for the development team once
you've actually then added the local
repository into your local computer then
the second action you want to use is a
push which is to actually push your
local files out to the master
environment so you use the command git
push origin master so one question you
may be asked is what is the difference
between a bare repository and a standard
way of initializing and git repository
so let's look through what is a standard
way so the standard way using git init
allows you to create a working directory
using the command git init and then the
folder that creates is the folder that
creates all the revision history related
to the work that you're doing in
contrast using the bare way you have a
different commands for setting that up
so it would be get in it - - bear and it
does not contain any working or checked
out source files locally on your machine
in addition the revision history is
actually stored in the root folder
versus a subfolder that you would have
with the normal git init initialization
so which of the following CLI commands
would you be used to rename a file
so we have guitar em get em v get r em -
r or none of the above
well in this instance it would be get em
V a question that you'll be asked around
commit is going to be what is the
process to revert a commit that has
already been pushed and made public and
there are two ways you can address this
the first is to actually address the bad
file in the new commit and you can use
the command git commit dash em and then
put in a comment for why that file is
being removed the second is to actually
create a new commit that actually undoes
all the changes that were made with the
bad commit and then to do that you would
use git revert and then the commit ID
and the commit ID
it could be something such as five sixty
zero nine three eight F but you'd have
to find that from the the commit that
you had made but that would allow you to
revert any bad files that you had
submitted so there are two ways of being
able to get files from a git repository
and you're gonna be asked to explain the
difference between get fetch and get
Paul so get fetch allows you to fetch
and download only new data from a root
new repository it does not integrate any
of the new data into your working files
and it can be undone at any time if you
wanted to break out the remote tracking
branches in contrast get pull updates
the current head branch with the latest
changes from the remote server so you
get all of the files and downloaded it
downloads new data and integrates with
the current working files you have on
your system and it tries to merge remote
changes with your local ones so one of
the questions you'll get asked about git
is what is a good stash so as a
developer you'll be working on the
current branch within a solution well
what happens if you come up with an idea
where it's something that will take a
different amount of time for you to be
able to complete but you don't want to
interrupt the mainline branch so what
you got to do is you can actually create
a branch that allows you to start
working on your own work outside of the
mainline branch and this is called get
stash allows you to be able to modify
your files without interrupting the
mainline branch so you once you start
talking about branching and get be
prepared to answer and explain the
concept of branching so essentially what
it allows you to do is have a mainline
master branch that has all the code that
the team is checking in and checking out
against but allows you to have an
indefinite number of branches that
allows for new features to be built in
parallel to the mainline branch and then
at some point being reintroduced to the
mainline branch to allow the team to add
in new features and so if we look
through the merge and get rebase these
are the two features that you'd be using
continuously to be able to talk about
how you take a branch and merge it back
into the mainline branch so on the
left-hand side that we have git merge
which allows you to take the code that
you're creating a merge it back into the
master on the right hand side what you
have is a slightly different approach
and this is for projects where you reach
a point in a project where you go okay
we're going to effectively restart the
project at this point in time and we
want to ignore the complete history
that's happened before that and that's
called git rebase and that would allow
you to rewrite the project history by
creating a brand-new mainline branch
that ignores all other previous branches
that have happened before it you can if
you want to very quickly easily find out
all the files that have been used to
make a particular commit so when
somebody asks you the question how do
you find a list of files has been
changed in a particular commit you can
actually say that all you have to go is
find the command git diff - tree - R and
then the hash that you'd use for the
commit and they would actually then give
you a breakdown of all the files that
have been made with that particular
commit a question you'll be asked when
you're talking about merging files is
what is a merge conflict and get and how
can it be resolved so essentially am
conflict is when you have two more
branches that are competing with commits
in gait and you have to be able to
determine which is the appropriate files
that need to be submitted and this is
where you would go in and to actually
help resolve this issue you'd actually
go in and manually edit the conflicted
files to select the changes you want to
keep in the final merge so let me go
through the steps that you would take to
be able to illustrate this when you're
talking about this particular question
in your interview now there are
essentially four stages the first would
be under the repository name you want to
select a pull request and you want to be
able to show how that pull request would
be demonstrated inside of github so
within the pull request there's going to
be a high lines of conflict markers and
you would be a select which conflicts
and you want to keep on which you want
to merge and which ones you want to
change so it's a step through how you'd
actually resolve a merge conflict and
the first step would be under github you
want to be able to pull the repository
name and then the pull request around
that repository in the pull request list
click the pull request with a merge
conflict and that you'd like to be able
to resolve now pull up a file that would
list out all of the conflicts for you
near the bottom of that file will be a
list of the requests that need to be
resolved and then if you need to make a
decision on which branches you want to
keep or which ones you want to change
that will have to be something you have
to put in instructions inside of the
file you'll actually see that there are
conflict markers within the instructions
which are going to ask you which files
you want to change which ones you want
to keep if you have more than one merge
conflict in your files scroll down to
the next set of conflict markers and
repeat steps four and five until you
resolve all of the conflicts you will
want to mark your file as resolved in
github so that the repository knows that
you are having everything resolved if
you have more than one file with a
conflict then you want to go then on to
the next file and start working on those
files and just keep repeating the steps
we've done up to this point until you
have all of the conflicts resolved and
then once you have all of the
resolutions created then you want to
select the button which
commit merge and then merge all your
files back into github and this will
take care and manage the resolution of
the merge conflict within github so you
can also do this through command line
and with command line you want to use a
get bash and so when you want to as a
first step open up get bash and then
navigate to the local git repository in
command line by using the CD change
directory and then list out the actual
folder where you actually are putting
all of your code and then you want to be
able to generate a list of the files
that are affected with the merge
conflict and in this instance here you
can actually see the file style guide MD
has a merge conflict in it and as before
with working with github you actually go
through and use a tech service and use
any text editor but as you go through
then edit out what you want to keep them
what you want to manage in your conflict
so you actually have a resolution that's
being created so that you'll be able to
then once you're using the conflict
markers you can actually merge your
files together so that the solution
itself will allow you to incorporate
your commits effectively into the
resolution once you've gone through and
applied your changes groups will then
merge the conflicted commits into a
single commit and able to push that up
to your remote repository I hope this
helps you in your interview with that we
reached the end of this complete get
tutorial I hope you enjoyed this video
do like and share it thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
some Kalon
[Music]